Let's go to our caller from the four oh one
area code.
Our friendly neighbors to the south in Rhode
Island I would rice.
Yes, that is you.
Yes.
Hello.
My name is Michael.
I live in one socket, Rhode Island,
wound socket very heavily.
I have a lot on my mind.
I have plenty of questions, but I got one.
Oh, can we just look in at the complete political
mess?
It reminds me a lot of the antebellum era,
like I feel like we're so divided, like how
can we coexist?
I don't feel like just me, I'm on, I have,
I'm on a spectrum, so just follow me.
Okay.
I'm like, we can't even, we don't seem to
agree on reality basically.
Yeah.
And just one side is this seems to just keep
on deem and I then that's at a point like,
do you see us as anti American?
And I'm beginning to see them identity American
and just how can we coexist?
How can we just ridiculous?
You know, you've gotten to one of the fundamental
issues that's going on right now, which is
if we don't even have a shared understanding
of the most basic truths about reality, I
don't know how we work together to solve anything.
And that's where we get these situations where
one party gets into power and gets a couple
of things done around the edges, getting around
the obstruction of the other party and then
the situation reverses.
And meanwhile, uh, it's the mass of people
that lose its people who are hoping to get
a raise, whose wages have been stagnant for
40 years.
If you're in the bottom 50% of the country,
it's a healthcare system that still doesn't
work for tons and tons of people, even people
who can't afford their premiums.
But it's still a terrible system.
I mean, you're right.
I don't have an answer.
I, this is one of the areas in which I am
least optimistic in politics, which is,
yeah, sorry.
The downward dating.
More concerned about, oh, what the moderates
think about, well, what, what about the center,
right?
Or the white working class, but to care about,
no, like I'm [inaudible] understand what I'm
seeing.
They're considered, they're worried about
a class, a group of voters that won't vote
for them.
You don't see Republicans caring about,
I don't think that's stupid.
I mean, I don't think we should write off
how certain part portions of the electorate
we'll see the policies of Democrats.
I actually think that's important.
And ignoring that is how you end up with terrible
candidates that lose election.
So I don't, I don't, I disagree with you that
it's bad to think about that.
But uh, I think it all has to happen sort
of like a broader context of understanding
the world in which a candidate is running.
But I, I don't think it's a bad thing for
Democrats to ask those questions.
I'd like these.
I know even just like we have like Biden who
thinks, oh, we can work with the Republicans.
No, we can't work with the Republicans.
We can't, we just can't.
Now you're talking.
Yes.
There's a difference between considering how
a white working class, we'll see the policy
of a Democratic candidate versus these completely
out of this world, these completely out of
this world ideas that as soon as we have a
Democratic president, Republicans are going
to work with us on stuff.
It's like, no, they're not.
We know from experience that they're not looking
at the first two years of Barack Obama's presidency.
Yeah.
Like can we, we should have had like this,
well this is my problem with the Democratic
Party there, but you don't have that.
Um, there was an, there was an interesting
article I read.
Um, Republicans understand powers.
There are, there are insane abortion bills
basically article.
Basically they sell how they understand power.
They're in power.
They want to do what they want and you're
going to do it no matter what.
Like I only Democrats had that spine, but
we want to have medicare for all.
So we're going to do it and we're going to
steamroll it.
Yup.
They seem to understand that.
And Democrats only only sometimes do listen,
really appreciate the call.
Great to hear from our folks down in Rhode
Island.
Hope to hear from you again.